voici les roches du vide bathurst rondes
qui ont environ 2 5 milliards d'années
et sur lesquels la ville de
johannesbourg que vous pouvez voir en
fonte et construite et ça c'est un
contexte parfait pour parler de
l'origine de la vie bonjour à toutes et
à tous ces clichés or notre cliché
l'émission sur les clichés qui servent à
combattre les clichés en biologie
évolutive et aujourd'hui donc on va
parler de l'origine de la vie origines
de la vie qui est source de beaucoup de
discussions de discussion et puis
surtout de deux conceptions fausse j'ai
envie de dire de d'idées reçues
idées reçues qui viennent de la part de
ceux qui évidemment ne croit pas en la
théorie de l'évolution mais aussi et
c'est sale et c'est de ça dont on a
parlé aujourd'hui les conceptions qui
viennent des gens qui défendent la
théorie de l'évolution mais qui
peut-être se trompe ou peut-être pas un
fonds qui sait qu'ici on va voir ça
donc souvent ce qu'on entend c'est
évidemment des gens qui ne colle pas
croire que que la vie est apparue comme
ça spontanément est ce qu'ils disent
ouais ce qu'ils disent c'est que la vie
elle n'est pas venue des cailloux comme
ça une commande doit de quelque chose
d'autre pour arriver à faire parvenir la
vie voilà donc ils veulent pas croire
que la vie soit venu de nulle part et
surtout pas des cailloux ce à quoi on
peut pas leur donner tort puisque la vis
et de la biochimie c'est pas du caillou
c'est pas du caillou
déjà c'est de la chimie organique donc
on peut pas dire que la vie soit
originaire du caillou ça vient de la
chimie organique c'est-à-dire la chimie
du carbone
mais surtout ce qu'on entend très
souvent
conception assez fausse qu'on entend
souvent c'est
la vie enfin la théorie de l'évolution
de toute façon n'importe pas ne s'occupe
pas de ça voilà la théorie de
l'évolution de toute façon n'importe pas
la réponse à la question d'où vient la
vie non plus que la théorie de
l'évolution il suffit simplement de
savoir comment ça évolue et c'est tous
les mécanismes qui rentrent en jeu bref
tout ce qui est a découlé du premier
ancêtre commun exactement exactement
donc donc vous avez typiquement la
discussion entre créationnistes et
évolutionniste ou le créationnistes diba
théorie de l'évolution elle dit que lier
ces des cailloux pour donner naissance
aux dinosaures
et vous avez l'évolutionnisme qui répond
me tuera importe quoi vais attendre mais
devant et cailloux les dinosaures tout
sa façon humour s'occupe que des
évolutions et donc c'est ap ap après
nikkei où on va dire après je taperai du
cac après l'udc on s'occupe de la
théorie de l'évolution elle ne dit rien
sur l'origine de la vie elle dit à
propos de la diversification de la vie
et notamment la diversification après
d'ancêtres en commun universel qu'on
appelle luc à toutes les histoires de
soupe primordiale vous oublier voilà
c'est ça la soupe primordiale c'est pas
le faire c'est pas la sphère des
évolutionnistes répondent généralement
la plupart des gens et ça on va apporter
un petit peu de nuances là dessus on va
porter un petit peu de nuances alors
déjà faut rappeler les termes lucas last
universal common ancestor le dernier
ancêtre en commun de tous les êtres
vivants n'est pas n'est pas la première
cellule vivante déjà ça faut commencer
faut commencer par le début dit qu'on
appelle ce que les est ce que les
scientifiques entendent par l'ucal
ancêtres en commun universel c'est
l'ancêtre en commun de tout ce qui vit
aujourd'hui donc et notamment l'ancêtre
en commun d'une bactérie d'un arbre et
d'un être humain par exemple voilà
c'était une cellule une cellule unique
et cette cellule unique elle avait déjà
de l'adn donc lucas il avait déjà de
l'adn il avait déjà une machinerie
cellulaire pour transformer cet adn arn
et il avait aidé voilà donc c'était
probablement une cellule que si on la
voyait aujourd'hui on l'appellera une
bactérie
oui voilà si on voyait jusqu'à
aujourd'hui on appellerait lucas une
bactérie mais voilà donc grosso modo
c'est ça l'idée cette cellule elle est
super évoluer déjà en réalité bucca est
déjà super évolué il a déjà une
machinerie cellulaire complexe parois
cellulaires déjà il ya déjà de la lienne
ensuite enfin
voilà lucas il est déjà très
sophistiqués comme comme comme cellule
au final et et il y a un énorme gouffre
entre de la chimie organique et lucas
déjà de la chimie organique de base et
lucas ce que lucas il a déjà une
histoire évolutive propres donc si on
considère que la théorie de l'évolution
ne s'occupe que de ski et descendant de
lucas et de la diversification de la vie
depuis du câble la théorie de
l'évolution des jeunes il se passe voilà
elles se passent de beaucoup d'éléments
de tout ce qui s'est passé finalement
avant lucas et c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'origine de la vie donc on pourrait
dans ce cas là donné raison aux gens qui
disent banon théorie de l'évolution ne
se ne s'occupe pas de ça puisque avant
ça finalement qu'est ce qui avait
d'ailleurs il y avait de la biochimie et
notamment de la biochimie alors la
première qu'est ce qu'on pourrait dire
du premier être vivant puisque lucas
n'est pas le premier être vivant mais du
coup l'ancêtre de luca ce premier être
vivant bah c'était une molécules à base
de carbone qui pouvait se reproduire
voilà qui pourrait faire qu'ils
pouvaient faire des copies d'elle-même
quoi
vous voyez on est au milieu des pros tc
magnifique
c'est dommage elle sent pas encore en
fleurs là ce sera dans quelques mois
on
voit les bourgeons des des procédés
[Musique]
mais revenons à notre donc l'ancêtre de
lucas la première la première chose
qu'on peut appeler vivante
et qui soi-disant n'intéresse pas les
évolutionnistes bien cet ancêtre de
lucas c'est une molécule à base de
carbone donc de la biochimie qui est
capable de faire des copies d'elle même
en utilisant de l'énergie à cette femme
c'est ça la définition de la vie la
définition de la vie c'est être capable
de se répliquer de se reproduire et
d'utiliser de l'énergie donc d'avoir un
métabolisme
donc
si cette molécule ancestrales
bon si cette molécule ancestrale a
existé et on suppose qu'elle a existé
évidemment
si cette molécule sont ancestrales à
exister bon et bien les évolutionnistes
les paléontologues notamment et puis les
mimiques les les gens qui font de la
biologie moléculaire qui étudient l'adn
ils vous diront que la détermination de
la nature de cette molécule
est de l'ordre de la biochimie
et pas de la théorie de l'évolution de
l'histoire de la série mondiale en des
tas de conseils pour essayer de faire
apparaître molécules capables de se
répliquer voilà
donc ça ce serait de la sphère de la
biochimie mais mais mais mais
là où justement on attaque le contre
contre clichés j'ai envie de dire c'est
que si cette molécule était capable de
se reproduire ça veut dire qu'il y avait
descendance avec modification et s'il
y'avait descendance avec modification
n'a rien évolution alors il ya évolution
c'est la base de la théorie de
l'évolution s'est hâté la sélection
naturelle si il y à descendance avec
modifications alors les molécules
théorique dont nous parlons
seulement celles qui se reproduisent le
mieux vaut être capable ensuite de
produire plus de des cinq ans et ainsi
de suite génération après génération de
molécules les molécules créant de
nouvelles copies d'elle même votre
évolué donc la théorie de l'évolution en
fait ça intéresse bien aux ancêtres de
luca en tout cas même si elle ne s'y
intéresse même si les gens qu'ils
étudient ne s'y intéressent pas
directement la théorie de l'évolution en
elle même est tout à fait tout à fait
applicable ouais applicable elle est
pertinente voilà elle est pertinente je
sais pas si vous avez remarqué ça monte
un peu
[Rires]
j'ai pensé johannesbourg on est à 8800 m
donc là l'air est un peu faim
l'oxygène est rare
donc à supporter lucas n'avait pas ce
problème car il n'y avait pas d'oxygène
à l'automne ou trop trop peu en tout cas
de toute façon il avait probablement pas
de mécanisme de
le respiration
donc voilà le la problématique de
l'origine de la vie
même si on a tendance à s'en éloigner un
peu en tant qu évolutionniste bas elle
est quand même enfin la théorie de
l'évolution est quand même tout à fait
pertinente
dans cette problématique et ça c'est ça
c'est quelque chose qu'il ne faut pas
oublier donc le cliché c'est l'évolution
dit que la vie vient des cailloux les
nombreux contres clichés inclus non
c'est pas des cailloux c'est de la
chimie organique et la chimie organique
on s'en fout non c'est bon on s'en fout
voyons si des noms mais la chimie la
chimie organique c'est attendez on va
vous montrer le paysage
alors donc
oui le cliché c'est la théorie de
l'évolution dit que la biodiversité
enfin que l'origine de la vie c'est les
cailloux alors non l'origine de la vie
c'est pas les cailloux c'est la chimie
c'est la chimie organique la chimie
organique y en a partout
indépendamment de l'existence de la vie
à tel point que ça devient compliqué à
certains moments de tracer la limite
entre ce qui est
organique non vivant et organiques
vivant
c'est donc c'est une limite qui est un
peu à l'appréciation de chacun donc il
n'ya pas de limite en fait entre la
chimie organique non biologique et la
chimie organique biologique c'est
jusqu'à près on a une définition sèche
de la vie qui est faux que ça se
reproduise il faut que ça utile faut que
ça ait un métabolisme quoi donc c'est
juste ça la définition de la vie qu'il
sépare le vivant du nom vivant il n'y a
rien de magique qui a pas de souffle
vital il n'y a pas de
deux choses d'ésotérique comme ça après
le problème de faire des petites boîtes
comme ça c'est que des fois il ya
d'autres trucs grandement la petite
boîte
forcément
un virus informatique ça se reproduit
sa utilisent de l'énergie de
l'électricité sait par contre c'est pas
à base de carbone il ya ici donc à la
limite vous voyez mais bon on peut jouer
avec les limites de ce qui est vivant et
de ce qui ne l'est pas et donc ça c'est
la première chose la deuxième chose
c'est le contre clichés qui est de dire
b de toute façon l'origine du vivant
c'est pas la théorie de l'évolution de
la théorie de l'évolution ne s'occupe
pas de l'origine du vivant bah en fait
bah voilà partir du moment où votre
molécule de base l'ancêtre de lucas se
trouve être se trouve être sujet à la
descendance avec modification il ya
forcément sélection naturelle et qui dit
sélection naturelle dit théorie de
l'évolution
voilà c'était clichés or notre cliché au
milieu des roches du précambrien de
johannesbourg de la vue sympathique le
berceau de l'humanité juste là bas donc
il suffit de faire quelques quelques
sauts dans cette direction quelques
kilomètres à vol d'oiseau c'est une
quinzaine de bornes voilà et vous vous
retrouvez dans les roches du pléistocène
qui ont donné dès les australopithèques
vous voyez une terre à tous une terre
riche pour les paléontologues
on vous dis à très bientôt sur notre
chaîne ciao
[Musique]